welcome to this video I'm playing jammie
Dodger again with white with white this
time usually we have this Carol con
stuff how I am I remember we also had a
taraji and exactly this line it wasn't
okay it was something like g45 and I was
winning a porn but it wasn't it wasn't
so clear cut still I am having a hard
time to believe it it's probably not
exactly this position but came scrap
home 25 mm-hmm g5 is hanging yeah well I
have no choice now need to take it
yeah this is not nice at all what is
there may be okay that I need to do
anyway I was thinking an f4 very very
crude yeah it looks like complete
nonsense f4 yeah but maybe the only
thing that really justifies all those
weak squares I have a good knight on d5
and this night this Bishop on g6 can be
attacked with f4 f5 so maybe I should
really play it for its really looking
like a crappy movement in form maybeee
form before takes the one look takes
takes takes Knight c-17
hmm not sure but still what else for
takes rook tags should be 497 should G
298 what a nonsensical position okay
let's do this anyway
he's got two cones him I didn't really
appreciate that move it's not only two
pawns it's really a more than shaky
position
hmm well the only thing keeping me alive
is that the f8 bishop is not it's not
great at the moment if it would come to
be six or something it's immediately
curtains I mean at the position is
terrible anyway but this would would
actually win instantly activating
somehow this Bishop I really want to
yeah get this pin going
93 mate I need to cover it
hmm yeah how does he win now the H cone
maybe
I try to do is just ruki a truck da twin
ff8 I mean just like simple chess but
it's probably not working but what else
I think he needs to move the rook get in
Bishop g4 as a threat Rock a two or
something should be shouldn't be too bad
I wonder look it to Bishop g2 but it's
not the end of the world actually okay I
won't be sure before in the mix of
course not when I meta gem and it'll be
gorgeous but it is an additional motif
that why it needs to worry about
you know that's the clock run down and
that probably is something I mean wow
why can I not take what's the big trick
I don't see it let's let's take the
bishop there
okay what is where's the mate i am
probably overlooking a medium
Bishop here and Bishop bag with rock g2
coming or something ah is this a mate
maybe it's perpetual should be 30
check
look g2
let's even meet rising being made I'm
stupid 93 is made okay yeah this was
what a position wow it's really cool to
look at the the computer assessment odd
i could play look f ATM and wow this is
bad it's not here I can take didn't see
that at all here this one keg I mean
this isn't too too great for white but
I'm not made anymore not mated with
quite a quite an improvement Bishop g4
would have won this it still super
dangerous this is a draw according to
the computer and this losses due to
Bishop g4 Bishop g4 is even a mate he
played this one which is a draw with kim
jiwon at this this losers i have no
defense now yeah i didn't find any there
wasn't anything I actually allowed the
maid now but I really didn't see him
something to prevent it computer wants
to play this one yeah yes at least it's
not a maid
yeah it's winning anyway probably with
the H pawn but it's a it's the defense
that leads to continue it was very very
tricky but of course I mean I I got into
trouble him this this was just bad bad
play yeah rock t3 is strong now yeah but
very complicated it's not a
correspondence game but can you say
thanks for watching